still live now Brean okay thank you okay
so and welcome everyone to today's
meeting of the licensing boards the
purpose of today's meeting is to decide
from the application for a license to
drive a private higher vehicle sorry my
computer and try to this meeting or
participant it's a previously check that
they can be heard and seen and can see
in here other members and double-check
this and to introduce everyone who's
present this remote meeting I plan to
ask that you confirm your attendance and
your role or job title when I say your
name sorry
so and councilor blendable just yeah I'm
here counselor Alan curry present
counselor boy Dexter here counselor
leshan era counselor Ellis Greene no
castle is Queen singer can you unmute
your microphone list she's not here she
is here she was here yeah Cassie green
is with us
she just needs to unmute a microphone
okay yep we can hear you now sorry
great Thank You councillor karina Huxley
yeah I'm here thank you
I'm counseling Deportes no counselor may
saunders counselor Mike Saunders I know
she's here and she's who I meet is a
microphone earlier counselor Harry
Scobie yes
come here counsel my shrub yes I'm here
I'm here and counselor Linda Ryan I'm
here
okay great thank you and if you have any
technical difficulties during the
meeting there please contact the
Democratic services office so on call
who will attempt to assist you they'll
put their phone numbers in the chat
and I would ask participants when you're
not speaking please mute your microphone
this minimizes the background noise and
will help everyone in listening to the
proceedings microphones will only be on
if the participant has been granted
permission to speak to gain one
permission to speak please very briefly
indicate on the chat to the right side
of the screen and I will then make a
note and go back to you once the person
speaking is finished and the Devron
present please ensure that the mobile
phones tend to silent and they are not
used to make a receive phone calls loud
meeting is in progress please also
refrain from checking emails or
conducting other business and ensure
that you are in a quiet room frequent
distractions for the duration of the
meeting recording please note this
meeting is being live-streamed for
members of the public except for any
item of business where exempt or
confidential information is considered
for exclusions present public from the
meeting in this instance a separate
private hangout meeting will take place
for that item only and the public
meeting will resume in its previous
digital location 30 minutes later unless
there is a reason to suggest an earlier
or later time members of the public
can't be filmed in this instance no one
authorized recording of the confidential
item of business is permitted to take
place the public meeting is broadcast
live on YouTube and following the
meeting the recording will be available
in the same location right apologies for
absence so we haven't had some apologies
for what an error all into pots is that
right that's correct
can we all just could we also just
introduce the officers that are on the
call as well just for clarity purposes
okay I'd like an introducing and Nicolas
here's
democratics officer and Alison Stuckart
licensing and officer and I'm a list of
everybody here so I and Charlotte kept
carly democratic services
missing else and gavin legal is that
legal officer
is everybody know you've missed me oh no
no penny how possibly miss you Penny's a
heads of the environment safety
neighborhoods safe or nameless oh yeah
right
we also have mr. cannon obviously who's
our applicant with us as well today and
what can I become okay super
okay thanks because are there any
declarations of interest
no okay and this guy remember proposed
the second admits the licensing board
meeting held on the 14th of April 2020
be approved and signed by the chairman
can I have a proposer for that please oh
I did that sound counselor Linda Wyatt
and a second our second
does anyone object to the removal of the
minutes
no okay and minutes of the last
subcommittee meeting and please clevon
remember propose and second at the
minutes of the licensing board meeting
held on the 14th of April 2020 be
approved and signed by the Chairman can
have a proposal for that place proposed
and so you can propose that council and
which is yep and seconds of please
oh sure I'll second thank you does
anybody an objective proof with the
minutes of the 14th of April 2010
subcommittee No okay moving on then and
it's fusion of public and press please
can I have members propose and second
that the public and press the exclusive
and meeting for the agenda item five as
it contains exempt information that's
applied to paradise for seventh or part
one of schedule twelve eight at the
Local Government Act 1972 as amended and
I'm a proposal for that place
Irish movie that's this guy being second
done I will Brendan Rodgers house the
Rogers
okay any objections to this
now that's fine okay so the cloak of
meeting which lots of live stream of the
meat of the meeting meaning that no
members of the public will be able to
see in the meeting at this point yeah
yeah so Jen
so we shall do that now the purposes of
the members of the public that are
watching the live proper we will be
turning the livestream this meeting off
in a very short amount of time please do
check back half an hour from now so that
will be